if
Well, good morning again Church. It is a joy to worship together
every time especially to begin this summer. Let me encourage you to stay connected.
It's really easy in the summer to get disconnected and as
we're in and out for vacations and such as you've
seen already. This is a really encouraging opportunity
to look deeply into God's word
what he has to say to us what we're going to
study over these summer Sundays is 10
of Jesus's parables.
That we might call stories with a purpose.
Out of the Book of Luke as we've been in Luke a lot this year.
So we're going to study these stories that have not just
a point but a purpose and something Eternal.
So take your copy of God's word and turn to the
Book of Luke chapter 8.
We'll find the first Parable there.
Luke chapter 8
Now there's a reason God led us to this one to study first and
it's not just because it's a really good Parable
as you'll see.
And it's not even just because Jesus told us
the meaning of the parable, which is really helpful.
It's also because in it Jesus also included
the reason why he even spoke in
parables.
So that's where we're going to start is we're going to look at a broad overview of The Parables
before we even get into this one, but we're looking at jesus' Big
why?
The context is found in verse 1.
Where Jesus was traveling all over the region. He was fulfilling back from
Luke 4 what he read as a prophecy of
his life. He was he was doing Miracles. He was healing people. He
was preaching the Good News of God's Kingdom.
That's why we subtitled the sermon series on Parables secrets
of the Kingdom.
Because that's what Jesus was doing.
He was using these real to life stories to
illustrate what the nature of
his kingdom was and is and and how to live
in light of it.
So these not just good stories to memorize. These are actually teaching
us about his kingdom.
And so we hear that and we might initially be really grateful that
that Jesus would take it off the top shelf and put on a low shelf
with some stories, right? Because we love pictures. We love videos. We're
all about that. Thank you Jesus for making it simple for
us.
You might think that.
Until we read what Jesus himself said about why
he used parables.
We see here in Luke 8 look at the back half of verse 8 down
through verse 10.
He had just told the parable we'll get to in a second. He said these things he
called out he who has ears to hear Let Him hear.
And when his disciples asked him what the parable meant he said
to you. It has been given to know the secrets
of the kingdom of God.
But for others they are in parables.
So that seeing they may not see and hearing they may not
understand.
Now that's actually a shortened quote from Isaiah chapter 6 where when
God called Isaiah into his ministry. He basically
told Isaiah which is really encouraging. He said
Isaiah. Nobody's going to listen to you.
As you go preach. Nobody's going to listen.
And that wasn't a punishment. It was to bring
about the salvation of the Gentiles eventually. We
see that through the story of Israel.
But Jesus Takes that concept of what God Said to
Isaiah and he applies it to his Parables Mark
4 actually adds a little bit to it.
He says the same quote. He says they may indeed see but
not perceive and indeed here but not understand lest they
should turn and be forgiven.
so you see
Jesus is saying Parables separate.
Parables show who's really in believing
and who's not believing?
That's what Jesus said in John 8 as well. He said many didn't understand
what he said because they were of their father the devil.
They were not of God.
First Corinthians 2 adds that you have to have the spirit of
God inside of you to understand the things of God. So so all
of this is coming back to the point.
That the parables are meant to divide.
So when you think about in that context?
Puts a little more weight on these Parables, doesn't it?
That it is really critical then for our eyes
to see for our ears to hear what
Jesus is saying.
Now listen when I say it's important for us to be able to hear what
I don't mean is what sometimes happens with me
with my wife.
You know guys, you'll probably understand what I'm saying here in
this is that whenever she will say something
to me. I will even acknowledge that
she said it to me and then I
have no idea what she said, right?
Don't nudge him. I saw you do that right like this. You understand
what I'm saying? Right? And so what happens is like the
the words the wavelengths of the sound goes in my
ear. It vertebrates my ear drum and
and I in my my brain says a
human is talking to me.
But then I have completely not listened at
all.
This is similar.
To what happens here in Luke 8 that
that as I was distracted and
I was focused on something else. I was seeing something else that's
more important than what she was saying.
When Jesus shares to the crowd around
him, what does he tell them he tells them
a parable.
This great crowd is gathering. And so
what happens in that moment as many people would hear
what he said, but not many people actually heard
Jesus.
Based on the response that we'll see here in a second.
That's what this Parable perfectly explains.
It shares. Why does not
everyone see Jesus as the king?
Right because we sit back here 2000 years later.
And we think about Jesus healing people and teaching what
he taught and and walking around doing the Miracles and we're
sitting here. Like, how did you guys miss that?
How does the only end up with like 12?
How does he only end up with a few at the end? How did so many
people miss it?
Well, this Parable will show us clear reasons why
people didn't respond to him.
Why they did not worship Jesus and
again as we study this Parable today, let's all
Not Just Hear It for those people. Let's
let's examine our own Hearts. Let's
let's make sure that we each are willing to
hear as well.
That we're willing to see Jesus willing to see his kingdom willing
to see what it looks like to actually follow this
Savior King.
This is for us just as much.
So here's the parable of the sower Luke 8 verses 5
through 8. This is the actual Parable Jesus told the
crowd.
He says A sower went out to sow his seed as
he sowed some fell along the path and
was trampled underfoot and the birds of the air devoured it.
Some fell on the rock.
And as it grew up it withered away because it had no moisture.
And some fell among thorns and the Thorns grew up
with it and choked it.
And some fell into good soil and grew and yielded a
hundredfold.
As he said these things he called out he who has ears to
hear Let Him hear.
So just put yourself for a moment. Remember this
crowds around I put yourself in the sandals of those who would
have heard this for the first time.
They're hearing Jesus say this story of the
sower. And and so there they're standing there as a
member of the crowd. They're intrigued by this Jesus figure. They may
have heard some things about him and they hear this and this
is all they get
It's one sentence couple sentences.
So you're sitting there thinking?
Does Jesus want us to learn about like how to harvest better as
he's teaching us principles of wheat? I don't
know and and so you think how they would
have responded if they were not already looking for the
kingdom to come.
They might have missed it.
They would have missed it pretty simply, right which again?
part of the point
of why Jesus was even using parables.
Well thankfully jesus' disciples were still
in the early learning stages as well. And so Jesus
continues in this first Parable here and he
explains the parable for us teaching us how to
interpret it thankfully.
This is down in verse 11. The disciples asked him. What does this
mean Jesus?
Told them that he talks in Parables for this reason now
verse 11. He explains the parable.
He says the parable is this the seed is the word
of God.
The ones along the path are those who have heard then
the Devil comes and takes away the word from their hearts,
so they may not believe and be saved.
And the ones on the Rock are those who when they
hear the word receive it with joy.
But these have no root they believe for a while and a
time of testing Fall Away.
And as for what fell among the Thorns they are those who hear but
as they go on their way. They are choked by the
cares and riches and pleasures of life and their
fruit does not mature.
As for that in the good soil they are those who hearing the
word hold it fast in an honest and
good heart and bear fruit with patience.
So first as Jesus explaining this whole Parable he starts
with what even is the seed?
We need to understand the principle and the points here. The first
is the seed that sower's out there sowing Jesus
says, that's the word of God.
Now when we hear the word of God, we think Bible.
Which is not wrong because these are God's
words to us. Yes, but in
the context more specifically Jesus most likely referring to
the gospel of the Kingdom.
Remember in Luke 4 he had pointed forward
to what he was coming to do part of that was to proclaim the
good news of the Kingdom. It's
the same message that the prophets of old had proclaimed
for out centuries that
the Messiah King was coming.
And now Jesus says the Messiah King is here.
It's me.
And God's kingdom is now coming on Earth as it
is in heaven.
Now we know that's going to look like things in the world are going
to change but primarily God's kingdom coming
on Earth is how God reigning more
and more in human hearts.
The more human hearts that he reigns in
that he's in charge of these the king over then the more
the world around us will look like the kingdom principles.
That a kingdom citizen will be living out, right?
so at first happens inside
Doesn't just like manufacture some kind
of laws or country and impose it
on the world. Now, it comes from inside out of
his citizens.
Well now we know today on the back side of Jesus's Ministry
that that change in ownership of our hearts
comes through repenting and believing the Gospel of
Jesus Christ that he lived died and resurrected in
my place for my sin to purchase my
salvation to purchase your salvation that that
is what he accomplished. So when I believe in
him
I'm a new creation. I'm a new citizen.
I'm a kingdom.
And the kingdom resident now.
And God brings his kingdom to Bear through me
through you through his people.
But what is evident from this parable?
Is that not everybody responds to
that word of the Gospel in faith and obedience?
Number Jesus used Parables to separate he's clear
in this Parable one of the four.
is actually his
And so what he does in this is he shares why not everyone
sees Jesus as king.
Why did three of the four soils miss it?
Well, the first group he says is because their hearts are dead.
The first group completely misses it because their hearts
are dead so their eyes and their ears are closed to
the kingdom of God.
This is the hard soil the pathway in
the parable, right? That's that's the walking path around
these these fields were not very big.
and so there was walking past around and sometimes even through
where the sower would walk and Scatter the seed
on his plot of ground and and the the Harvester later
would come and walk on those Pathways to harvest in the fruit
of his labor and then Travelers at
times would walk through fields and they would walk on these Pathways which
would
compress press down Harden the
soil on the walkway the pathway, right?
This is the hard soil.
but notice notice
These heard the word too. Right?
Did you see how many times throughout that passage?
They heard they heard they heard every
one of the soils heard including the hard soil.
The sower was scattering the seed and some of
the seed fell along the path as well.
It just would stay on the top.
exposed
never able
to take root
So what happened those birds flew in?
Snatched it away.
Well, Jesus says that's what happens.
to people who have hard soil
the devil
comes in and takes away the word from
these people's hearts so that they may not believe and
be saved.
So how does somebody get to that hard soil?
How does somebody get there finally?
Well, this is primarily someone who is so hardened by
sin that they are blinded to the gospel.
They're unmoved by the things of God.
Their consciences are seared to the point where they don't hear
it goes in one ear and it goes out the other ear. They're not
at all affected by God's truth in any way.
It's like you're sitting on a plane before takeoff.
And that flight attendant is up there and and they're sharing life
and death emergency procedures.
I want to watch a movie on my phone.
Like that's what we do, right? We we just
completely disregard what that person's saying.
Now we won't never need that.
We're fine.
Until you actually need it. Right and you're like, where's the exit?
You know, you you don't know but we have chosen to just
write it off. We're hard to it because we've
heard it so many times.
We think we know it already.
And we choose to watch or read something else and completely
disregard.
So think about that initial crowd.
Who would have been the hard soil?
Well, the Pharisees were hard soil because later
people listening to this wanted to
kill Jesus just a few months later.
And so we know that's hard soil obviously.
but also
hard soil people would have been those
Who listened in to what Jesus had to say?
kind of shrug their shoulders
moved on down the road.
whatever
fine good. Okay, interesting and move
on.
That's hard soil, too.
And listen, you don't have to be an atheist.
To have hard soil like that in your heart.
in fact Hebrews 3 warns us
says take care Brothers lest there
be in any of you an evil unbelieving heart leading
you to fall away from the Living God.
But exhort one another every day as long as
it is called today that none of you may be hardened.
by the deceitfulness of sin
remember he's writing that to people who are supposed to
be believers.
He's saying to people who are in the church.
Take care that you don't fall away. Take care that
you don't have a hardened heart because of
the deceitfulness of sin.
And this hardening can occur over time. It doesn't
happen immediately. It's an overtime Harding like
a fossil right a fossil hardens over a long
period of time where you just forget God and
you function like an atheist.
A pastor in our area wrote a book about that Christian atheist.
You have all the right language. You have all the right words and you talk about
like you're You're Everything Is Right on the outside
but you function like you don't
even believe God exists.
You live your life on your own you don't depend on him and
that is hard-heartedness.
So Hear Me If You Are unmoved by the things of
God
If you have no desire to pursue God in any
way if you're if you have no desire to be with his people with
brothers and sisters to exhort you and encourage you then see
the dangerous position you're in.
See that your heart might be hard. It
might be dead.
Be concerned about that.
It's the first reason people don't respond to Jesus as
king is because their hearts are dead.
He gives us a second reason here.
It's because people's hearts are afraid.
He says people.
have
fearful
Hearts they're afraid.
This is that rocky soil in verse 13.
Now this is interesting this soil the rocky soil initially. It
seemed to be good, right?
They received the word that they had heard.
And there was even a lot of joy that comes with it right away.
But it turned out to have no root.
It did not last when they were tested.
It withered under the Heat.
Over time they proved they did not really give their lives to
it in the first place that it did not take Deep Roots into
their soul.
Even though it looked good for a while.
We're coming up on July 4th. So this will happen a lot. But these these were
the ones Around Jesus who were like Roman candles. You know what I
mean by a Roman Candle just shooting little flares out one at
a time. Probably 10 of them.
These were the people who were around Jesus at the
time who were glowing with amazement at his
teaching at his miracles and they're just cloud like
Jesus is a great man. You're awesome is the best thing we've ever
seen. We love you Jesus.
But quickly fizzled out when trouble came.
And the Romans pressed in the Pharisees started asking questions.
I don't know. I don't know who this guy is.
Listen, I fear that that's coming from American Christianity at
some point.
that when the real persecution comes
when the real pressure hits our numbers
shrink dramatically.
When those who are in it only for the benefits.
slip away
It would not be the first time this has happened.
Happened even 2,000 years ago first John
2:19, they went out from us, but they
were not of us for if they had been of us. They
would have continued with us.
But they went out that it might be complain that
they all are not of us.
And they weren't really Believers to begin with.
Listen, it is so simple and easy to rejoice in
times of prosperity to rejoice
when things are easy to rejoice when things are
great on Sunday mornings. It's easy to lift your hands and and say
we put a fish sticker on my car. My profile is gonna
look some way on Facebook. Like I'm gonna do it. It's really easy when it's
times of prosperity.
But the deepest walk with God comes through
times of suffering.
Comes in the midst of the pain whenever you must
stand through the suffering you must look
beyond the suffering.
The rocky soil is afraid.
afraid of what people might think
afraid of suffering and pain
afraid of death
The rocky soil has not trusted that
rooting yourself in Jesus is worth
whatever comes.
So we have dead hearts.
fearful hearts
the third heart soil condition
why people don't see Jesus king is because their hearts are worldly.
Some don't see Jesus as king because of worldliness.
This is that thorny soil.
That choked out what was seeming to
grow?
Again, these people heard the word and they appeared to
be true, but they did not produce fruit. It
didn't mature meaning it never actually came about
because the cares of the world
the deceitfulness of riches
The desires for the pleasures of life choked out
the life-giving nourishment that that plant
needed to grow.
Kept the Sun from shining. It sucked all the water out of the soil.
It kept it choked out.
Easily this can happen to us too, right?
Again, let's see ourselves here where we take our eyes off
of Jesus and we fix them on the things of this
world Where We crave more and new and better.
That's what Jesus said in Luke 12. We must take care be
on your guard against all covetousness against
greed.
For one's life does not consist in the abundance of his
possessions.
It's greediness choking out what God
wants to do. It's also things like where we're focused on
all the things the world's focused on like celebrities and and
sports and social media.
pleasure
entertainment
politics
your body your car your lawn. I mean whatever so many
other things can can creep in and choke
out now all those things. Are they evil?
No, not necessarily. Those things can actually be good for our
lives. They can be good to spend time on
but as soon as you take a good thing and you
make it a God thing, then it becomes a bad thing.
Because here's what happens when you start to find that you're getting discontent.
And whatever anything you get discontent and
you start to seek satisfaction in any of those other
things and you're looking for this to fill you in this
to fill you and this to fill you. That's when it actually destroys you.
Because what it does is it chokes out
the work of God's word in your life.
I think of
someone like King Herod.
Who is says gladly heard John the Baptist's
worth?
John the Baptist was the prophet that preceded Jesus and so
John the Baptist was a famous preacher. He was preaching hard
repentance and King Herod. Like I love this guy.
I want to hear him more bring him in.
until herod's lust
overtook him
And at that young girl's request.
He had John beheaded.
He was choked out what God was doing.
choked out by lust
Or even when you think of the Rich Young Ruler and Mark chapter
10.
Who refused to follow Jesus because he would have had
to give up his entire Fortune.
or even Judas
Who sold out his friend for a couple pieces of silver?
It's thorny soil choking out his first
John 2 says don't love the world or anything in the world. If
anyone loves the world the love of the father is not
in him for all that is in the world the desires
of the flesh the desires of the eyes the
pride of life. It's not from the father. It's from
the world.
So do you see how dangerous materialism is?
It's one of those respectable sins that Jerry Bridges talks about that we can
just like it's okay as long as we're not earning our money unethically we're
okay.
It's dangerous.
This is how thorny the cares of the
world can be the deceitfulness of riches the
desires for other things. None of it comes from God
and what it does. It chokes out God's work
in your life.
Comes from your flesh it comes from the and it comes from the world around us and it's
all infecting our hearts.
And can destroy us through making us that bad soil.
So what do we do in response?
We look at this. We've heard the parable about the sower scattering
seed on the plot of ground. And now we've seen
why Jesus people reject Jesus as
their King. Why do they do it? Well now we've seen it. So what do
we do now?
We know he's talking to us, too. So, how should we respond to
this story with a purpose?
I'd imagine as I studied through I was
confronted by this as a we've walked through this you've already been subtly confronted with
this as well.
Right about right off the bat. We see that each of us should examine
our heart for the condition the quality of
our soil.
Right, that's just the natural reading of this as you
read through it. You're just like which soil am I?
How's my heart? Am I this am I that
Again, this is pointing us to the nature of God's kingdom. It's showing us
that every single one of us in this room.
Every single person watching online is
either hard soil rocky soil thorny soil
or good soil.
every one of us
and listen, I don't know that for you.
I can't tell that only you and God actually know the
answer that question.
Only I and God know that answer for me.
Because again notice some of the soil look good initially.
It had the appearance of godliness, but it denied it's true power.
What that means is that you might be able to deceive other
people for a while.
Might be able to put on the facade of Christ like Behavior.
You cannot trick him.
And it won't last.
You might try to produce the fruit for a while, but it will not
last so that's the question today.
at the deepest core of Who You Are
What is the quality of your soil?
In your heart. What is the condition of your
soil?
Is it hard?
and unfeeling
dead to the things of the Lord.
Just don't care.
Is it Rocky and shallow?
Where you're more afraid of what people think about you than what
God thinks about you.
Is it being choked out?
by the Thorns of the world
where you're a lover of self and money and pleasure rather
than a lover of God.
It's the question he's asking us and and listen be
careful. Be careful not to deceive yourself.
That this is just a season.
It's just a season.
Where you're you're blind to the realities of your life.
Where you you have a view of yourself? That's too
high.
Be careful not to deceive yourself that you think this is
who I am but really everything in your life points to something else.
Plus just think about even if it isn't even if it is
only a season.
Why would you want to stay there?
Why would you want to stay in the thorny Iraq you're dead. So why would
you want to remain there?
When the good soil is an opportunity.
And so if you run a soil test right now and you find that you're
not good soil. What do you do?
Okay. I'm not I see these this is me.
What do I do?
You repent?
And turn away from whatever is poisoning your
soil right now and you run to Jesus.
You turn back to Jesus.
Hosea 10 says this break up your untiled ground.
It's time to seek the Lord.
He's talking to Israel talking to their their how overwhelmed
they are how they're completely walked
away from God. It's hard ground Hosea. The
prophet says break it up.
It's time now to seek the Lord. Why are you waiting?
It's not worth it. Stop living that way break it
up and let's seek the Lord. That's what he's saying
to you right now. Because remember the point of the parable in
the end like the sower wants to harvest the point
God's desire for his people is for
us to be good soil.
That's what he wants for his people. He wants each one of
us to glorify your God with the fruit of
your life as good soil.
That's what he wants not only to examine and kind
of sit in there and be like man. I'm really bad soil right now
and just kind of soak in that you get depressed by that. No, he's also
saying flip it glorify your God with the
fruit of your life.
You can be good soil.
And that's going to glorify your God. So if
you have ears to hear it today.
It's what Luke 8:15 says the good soil. What
is it characterized by it's those who
hold the word fast.
In an honest and good heart and
they bear fruit with patience.
That seed of the word the gospel plants deeply
into their souls.
They have a healthy honest Kingdom motivation and
they bear fruit along the
way that's good soil.
because remember
all four of the soils heard the word
even the Rocky and thorny soils seemed to accept it
seemed to receive it. But the
only one of the four soils that actually produced fruit
was the good soil.
one fourth of this illustration is actually
his
And if you think okay that that's why
I want to be good soil. But then what happens when that seed is planted
in the soil just like that plant can't produce fruit on its own unless
it remains in the soil that's nourishing it
you and I cannot produce the fruit of
God unless we abide in Jesus.
It's John 15. The whole point of that is that
when we abide in Jesus, he will
produce fruit through us.
And fruit that glorifies him not glorifies us.
The fruit is cherished by other people.
And it's honoring.
The lord of the Harvest it's what Matthew 5 says
that Jesus says let your light shine before others. So
they may see your good works. Yes, that that might bring arrogance and
pride when I think now look they're gonna watch us do good things all
this. No, he says let them see your good works and give
glory to your father who is in heaven.
That's where the glory goes whenever you produce the
fruit. God is producing through you.
It's his work.
So we want to be good soil, right?
Clearly of the four it's a simple Parable. That's what the parables
are. So simple. Yes, so deep, right.
We want to be good soil. We need to be good soil. How do
you ensure that you are?
And that you'll be able to produce this good fruit.
Well first remember
the nature of God's Kingdom
you are good soil when you make sure
your heart is soft and broken
and humble.
So that the word of God can take root
in it.
That you recognize your fallenness you recognize your
need for him. You truly grasp. You can't save yourself.
You can do nothing on your own you say all of that.
You mean it in your heart and you come to him for help. You
don't try to do it yourself. You don't try to say I can handle this
I can buck up. I can strengthen up. I can do these things myself.
I don't need God you don't say that at all. You say
God. I can't do nothing apart from you.
And when you repent and turn away from that hardness
from that fear from that worldliness and you
say God I'm done with that and I want you you come
to him and Faith. That's when he makes you good
soil.
You can't make yourself good soil. That's what
he does in you.
So if you have ears to hear Church listen to this today, Jesus is
calling right now.
He's saying to you unbeliever. Come to me
to be good soil. He's saying to you believer with rocky soil
right now with thorny Soul right now, he's saying come to me.
Come to me. I will make you good soil. I'll
make you listen. He say I'll make you the kind of soul that
doesn't care if there's birds flying around.
That doesn't care. If the Sun is scorching. It doesn't matter
if Thorns are growing up because I'm gonna rip them out.
He wants you to be that kind of soil.
And he'll make you that good soil because then what
he does with that good soil. Is he produces good fruit that glorifies him?
And good fruit that benefits others as he takes that fruit.
Just imagine that take the metaphor a little
bit further, right? He takes that fruit and he opens it up. He takes
the seeds out of that and he begins to plant it in other
other fields around the world nearby us
to the ends of the Earth wherever he's taking
our fruit and he's producing more and more
and more through us.
for his glory
it starts Church.
by abiding in Jesus
To make you good soil and to produce the fruit he wants to
produce through you if you are anything else right now run to
Jesus.
Abide, and he will change you.